next is emery yorko
hi emery could you please share your
slides
am i pronouncing your first name
correctly uh yeah
thank you so emory is a
phd student at carnegie mellon
and he is interested in all things
satisfiability but in particular
applying satisfiability to math
and uh today is going to talk about
applications of sad solvers to this
extraordinarily hard problem called the
collapse conjecture
uh emery we can't see your at least i
cannot see your
uh screen um can you see it now
yeah now i can see just a second so
uh maybe in presentation mode it's not
working
um can you see it now yes i can see it
yes so please go ahead and give a talk
thank you so much
all right um thank you for the
invitation
i'm very excited to be talking about
this
so as the title suggests this is our
attempt
at tackling the collapse conjecture
via automated methods that are based on
string rewriting systems
specifically their termination a method
for proving termination called matrix
interpretations
which uh uses satisfiable test solvers
in the
process so this is joint work with scott
aronson
and mine hoyla
yeah so this doesn't require much
introduction but
as you well know several open problems
in mathematics were solved
using computer-assisted approaches or
purely computer
uh reliant methods
so most of these instances we're solving
a finite but really large search problem
in general for instance when you
use satisfiability to refute a formula
you're
solving a finite search problem or when
you're
finding some counter example uh to a
statement
you're again solving a finite search
problem it's rarer that one gets to
uh solve instances of problems that are
in general undecidable
so termination is one such instance and
there are beautiful techniques developed
to prove termination
of string rewriting automatically and
in this work uh in okay single sentence
we are look we are going to look at
variants of the collapse conjecture and
see what we can achieve
using the techniques that have been
developed for automatically proving
termination of string rewriting
and more specifically we will design a
rewriting system that is terminating if
and only if the collapse conjecture
holds
and spoiler alert we will fail to prove
it to be terminating
but we will look at some weakenings of
the problems and a problem
and see what we can achieve and i will
show some partial results
so a draft of this paper is available at
this link
in case uh you want to check it out in
about 10 days we will also
put a full version on archive and
this should this work will appear at
cade this year
so i'm assuming that not everybody in
the audience is
familiar with rewriting so i will
introduce it
uh quickly via examples i won't go into
too much technical detail but i just
want to give you
uh the intuition and also show you the
notation for
uh that we will use so in strictly
writing
uh it is best thought of as a
non-deterministic model of computation
that works with strings so we have an
alphabet
of uh symbols uh we have rewrite rules
uh denoted l to r which map
some string to another string so this
is the replacements that we can do uh in
parts of the string
and the collection of rewrite rules
constitutes a rewriting system
so formally this is a relation over uh
strings
over this alphabet and then we also have
this
rewrite relation which is induced by the
rewriting system
and this is the relation describing the
strings for which you can write one into
another
using some application of a rewrite rule
in the string
in the system so here is an example
we have a single rule system r uh
with the rule a b b a and generally i
won't specify the alphabet we'll just
take it implicitly
to be the all the symbols occurring
in the rewriting system so here's a
sample
rewrite sequence so the
sequence of applications of this rewrite
relation we will call a rewrite sequence
so here i'm showing the part of the
string that we are applying
the rule to we have a single rule in
this case
so we have this string we can
pick some part of it that matches this
pattern a b
and then rewrite it into ba so we
rewrite it obtaining this string
and then we repeat the same process
[Music]
continuing until no rule can be applied
and which happens when all the b's are
pushed to the left of the string and all
the a's are approached to the right of
the string
so the interesting property of the
rewriting systems that
we will look at is termination so a
system
is called set to be terminating if there
is no infinite chain of rule
applications
so where each of these x's are strings
over the alphabet that we have
so note that this is a universally
quantified statement over all strings
and all rewrite sequences
so we are not prescribing some strategy
for applying the rewrite rules or
prescribing some starting language
a system is terminating if for all
strings and all possible rewrite
sequences
there is no infinite chain so the
rewriting sequence has to come to an end
again here are some simple examples uh
the last two are not so simple
so this is the one that we saw so this
is easily seen to be
uh terminating because it moves a's to
the
right of the string and then b is to the
left of the string
and stops when all the b's are
accumulated on the left and a's are
accumulated on the right
so these two are like very trivial
examples of non-terminating and
terminating systems so this is
non-terminating because you can keep
increasing the length of the string by
uh right rewriting a single a anywhere
in the string into
two a's and this is like doing the
inverse
so you keep reducing this length of the
string
until a single a remains
so you can't keep writing rewriting
indefinitely
so this one has a loop uh again a
trivial loop
so you can look at some figure out some
a
and then rewrite it into b and then
rewrite it back into a again
obtaining a loop so this one is a
peculiar one so it's
very nicely symmetric and small but it's
not at all obvious whether this is
terminating or not
and it is terminating although
this wasn't known for a long while so
this one is also
kind of small small alphabet as well
just two rules but it's open whether
this is terminating or not
so nobody knows right now
so for proving termination uh several
techniques have been developed
and the the good reference for this is
the badr nibikov textbook
so we can characterize termination
uh as the existence of some well-founded
order
over strings such that
for all strings if you can rewrite it
into another string using some rule
application
then according to this order the string
should decrease
and since the order is well founded you
cannot keep rewriting
so at infinitum so you cannot have
infinite chains of decreasing
strings so this shows that the system is
terminating
but this is like an infinite is a
condition over infinitely many strings
that you have to check
so it's not very amenable to automation
instead the following
approach is used so i'm describing it a
bit abstractly here
so you can translate any given symbol in
your alphabet into
an element so this brackets means that
you're translating it into another
element in some domain so this is the
translation
and this domain is going to be already
equipped
with a well-funded order so
we don't want to explicitly figure out
an order on strings
instead we will use another domain and
then we want to
we show that for all the rules
if you extend this translation of
symbols
into strings in some manner and
furthermore if
under this translation uh this order
holds
uh for the disorder relation holds for
all the rules
then uh your system is terminating so
this is
here i've uh compressed the conclusions
of several theorems
while omitting some details but this is
like the general idea and this is called
the interpretation method
so now i'll show you a very trivial
example
so consider this system again we can
interpret uh this there's a single
symbol we can interpret it as just
one and the domain that
we are translating this to this to is
the natural numbers
and to strings we uh extend this
additively
by that i mean the interpretation of a
string is the sum of the interpretations
of the symbols that it has
so then uh you see that you have
this decrease by rewriting the string
according to this interpretation
and this suffices to show that the
rewriting system
t is terminating
now with the sudden shift of gears
we can also translate the symbols into
functions uh
more generally than numbers and for
instance for
this system uh you may observe that
this additive translation doesn't really
work because
a b is going to have the same
interpretation as b a under
whatever trans whatever interpretation
you have as long as you're extending to
strings additively
so instead you may consider functions
and extend to strings
in a compositional way and by then i
mean that the interpretation of a b
is the function that is the composition
of a and b
if you can ensure that this function
dominates this function the other
function then
this also serves as a an interpretation
method proof
and this lends itself very well to
automation for certain
templates of these functions that we can
pick
so one very effective method that was
invented by hofbar involvement in 2006
is to translate these into affine
functions
over the natural numbers uh
vectors of natural numbers for some
fixed the
that you pick and this is also extended
to strings compositionally
and this means that if you compose
these interpretations for the symbols to
get the interpretation of a string
you get another fine function so
everything is interpreted in terms of
fine functions
and then you equip it with some order
that is defined as follows
so a vector is greater than another
vector according to this
order if it is greater than or equal to
component wise
and furthermore if it's it is strictly
greater
in the first element so it turns out
that this satisfies all the technical
requirements that you have and uh
under this uh you get the ability to
search for
interpretations uh of this kind
automatically
specifically we look for interpretations
that satisfy this relation
so l and r are uh the left-hand side and
the right-hand side of some rule
and these matrices and
these vectors are the interpretations
that you have for these
under some fixed interpretation of the
strings
if you can check that this holds for
all x uh then you get an inter you have
an interpretation
you have a termination proof and the
uh very successful idea here has been to
encode all of the resulting constraints
from this as a set instance so in the
end you have a formula
that is satisfiable if an appropriate
interpretation exists so you can use a
sat solver to
see if it exists and if you can find one
then that proves that
the system that you have is terminating
now i'll explain it a bit more
concretely with an example
so recall this one so this was well
known for
[Music]
not having having approved for a long
while
not just automatically but in you know
nobody uh could prove in any way whether
this was terminating and the first ever
proof of this was found
automatic proof of termination of the
system was found automatically using
matrix interpretations
and just compactly it's these so
under these interpretations all of the
rules have the decreasing
interpretations
as i showed uh here so with respect to
this order
and here i'm showing you the resulting
fine functions
uh from composing the uh fine functions
for the symbols
and here we are performing a check
that is for uh
that has to hold for all vectors so you
can
do it uh decidably by
comparing since you have this order you
can do it decidably by comparing the
matrices and the vectors element wise
and turns out that this order holds if
uh element wise the matrices are greater
than or equal to
uh on the left-hand side compared to the
right-hand side and the same holds for
the
vectors and furthermore you require that
the first element
of the vector decrease strictly
so this constitutes a proof that the
system is terminating
again there are a few uh more
constraints that i'm
omitting but you know i'm just trying to
give you uh the intuition
so moving on uh although this needs
maybe no introduction
uh let me just fix notation so this is
the call-outs function
if you have a even integer
you divide it by two if you have an odd
integer you multiply it by
three add one and then it will become
odd so
i even saw you divided by two so the
collats conjecture the notorious
conjecture
says that for all positive integers
iterated application of this
function reaches one and then
keeps going as one two one two and it's
stuck in that
in that cycle um
so this has been checked uh up to
as of this year two to the 68.
that all of the trajectories do indeed
reach one
although you know we are nowhere near uh
finding a proof of this and so we will
design a rewriting system that's
terminating if and only if this
conjecture holds
and such a rewriting system actually
exists
and was invented by zantema hans santema
in 2005.
i won't explain it in too much detail
but i just wanted to show you
and you can view this as encoding the
computation of a turing machine with
elastic tapes
that is you have let's say a unary
representation of a number
on a tape and then you can by applying
these rules contract
or by applying this will expand the
tapes of the strings
of the turing machine
so the symbols are suggestively named so
ones indicate
the ones in the unit representation h
indicates the
head of the turing machine and along
with the state so it's having
a number at this state so these diamonds
are the blank
symbols on the tape uh this shift is the
shift operator
uh again and calls the position of the
uh
the head on the tape and this
moves the head leftward
without changing the value of the string
and this t
serves as what the head does while it's
tripling the number so xanthema showed
that the above system
is terminating if and only if the
collapse conjecture holds
so the forward direction of this
implication is uh
kind of easy to see once you become
familiar with this system
specifically you have the following
rewrites possible
so if you have the unity representation
of 2n on the tape and the head is
on the left of the string then there
exists a rewrite sequence
that allows you to get to n and
if you have the representation of two n
plus one
then you get to the unit representation
of applying the collapse map onto n plus
one which is
three n plus two so then uh
if this is terminating indeed for all
reading sequences then it is terminating
for these sequences as well which
shows you that the corresponding collets
trajectories are terminating
but this system using linear
representations
we argue is not very amenable to
automated approaches
specifically if you consider a
simplification of this system
that is like trivially terminating so
you may adapt this to compute the
function that divides by
2 and multiplies by 3 as long as the
result is an integer and then stops when
the number is
not divisible by 2 anymore so that leads
to a 4 rule system for which
termination is uh trivial to see but no
automated method has ever succeeded
so we will design an alternative system
uh for which that problem
and even some more difficult problems
that are still easier than the collapse
conjecture
becomes solvable and it relies
on a few simple observations
so we will work with a mixed binary
ternary representation
of the numbers instead of a unit
representation
so we observe that we can view binary
representations of the numbers as
compositions of uh the functions
uh that correspond to the true bits and
the false bits so the false bit
multiplies a number by two uh true bit
multiplies by two and adds one
and also we have like a constant
function denoting uh
one so as an example so we can write 12
in binary in this manner so this is the
most significant bit
and then you can translate that to
a function view by
i think i guess an application of
corners rule
[Music]
in this manner so you revert all of the
symbols
so you get 0 0 1 1 you replace zeros by
false
uh ones by true and you replace the
rightmost one
by this constant so then you can check
that
evaluating this is 1 and then
evaluating this gives 3 and then
evaluating this
is 6 and evaluating this gives 12.
so why are we doing this well because
this has some uh
nice properties uh regarding the collets
function
so specifically division by two in
binary corresponds to
just erasing uh the uh
what one of uh the the
the least significant bit so in the
function view
it corresponds to just deleting this f
and if you apply that to 12 you get six
which has this representation and then
you can repeat it again
getting three so now uh we have an old
number
now collet's function involves dividing
by two but also
multiplying by three and adding 1 which
is not so easy to express
using just binary but if we also had a
function let's say
of this kind then we could write let's
say
3x plus 1 which gives us 10 in this
manner by composing
uh additionally with this
h so you can uh
iterate on this idea and end up with a
binary ternary system mixed binary
internal system
so the symbol f and t
uh correspond to the zero and one uh
so the binary bits the zero one
two functions correspond to the ternary
digits
zero one two and these functions serve
as
the uh markers the beginning and the
end of string markers that we will use
again an example so we can for instance
write uh 19 in this way
in the mixed representation so this is
the string view
and you you may view uh these this zero
as a ternary digit this
uh false this f as a binary digit and so
on
and in the function mu it corresponds to
this composition
now we would like to apply let's say the
collapse function
to this representation but unfortunately
from this by just looking at this
representation we can only say that this
uh is a number of the forms three x plus
one
so we are unable to recognize its parity
uh immediately
if this was a binary digit then we would
be able to recognize its parity
immediately
so we will rewrite parts of the string
in such a way that its value doesn't
change but in its representation
this function is a binary function
or a function that corresponds to a
binary digit
so specifically we will rewrite we will
swap uh the basis of these
adjacent positions so we have one
f x evaluate to three x plus one
uh you can rewrite it uh by moving
a binary digit outside and moving the
turn digit inside but then
you know while doing so we also want to
ensure that we don't change the value of
the
string so these functions are picked
accordingly
this shows that we could replace this
1f with 0t
to arrive at this number still
representing 19
with a single modification now we are
able to recognize its parity
so we can apply the collets map at the
rightmost stands
because this representation says that
this is a number of the form 2x plus 1
for some x so mapping that to
[Music]
the uh value that the collets function
would map it to
uh would uh entail replacing
this part of the number uh
with uh these two symbols so
specifically
you you had a number of the form two x
plus one
you would like to uh make it a number of
the form three x plus two for the same x
um so you can do that by deleting this
and instead instead of its place uh
putting two
which we interpret as three x plus two
so in this way you simulate uh the
call-outs functions the application on
the string
in a single step as long as the
rightmost
end is a binary digit
so in this manner you can work out all
of the rules that you need to have
and end up with this system whose
equivalence
whose termination is equivalent to the
collat's conjecture as in the previous
case but this is
using a different representation so
these nine rules that you see on the
right
are the auxiliary rules that serve to
move binary digits towards the right end
of the number so that we can apply the
collets
map in a single step single rewrite step
these two rules are just applying the
collateral so if it's
a number of the form 2x you rewrite it
into a number of the form
x and this we have already seen
so in order to you know have some
practice with it
this is an example sequence and how this
would
work so suppose you have this
representation of 12
so again this doesn't end with a binary
digit so we would like to rewrite it
and we rewrite it according to this rule
f0 into zero if
obtaining a representation that ends
with a
binary digit now we can freely apply the
collats
map so we use this rule to rewrite it
into this string
which gives us six and in this manner we
continue
until we derive one which is represented
uniquely by this string
which we cannot rewrite further so
this rewriting sequence witnesses
determine the convergence of this
collets trajectory so this system is in
some ways better than the unity system
uh because it lends itself better to
uh automation but we of course failed to
solve the cause conjecture with this so
what one does when failed to solve the
problem is look at partial problems or
like easier instances of the problem
so one non-trivial test that we subject
this system to is uh a variant of the
collapse function
that herschel farquhars studied in 2005
so this is known to be terminating and
you obtain this variant by
introducing an additional case to the
collets map so if
the number is 1 modulo 3 then
you subtract 1 and then divide by 3.
otherwise you apply the original
callouts map so forecast showed that
you can prove inductively via case
analysis
that this function is convergent
and using the same idea as before we can
translate all of these rules so
observe that there are actually five
cases here only written together some of
them are written together since they
apply the same function you can
translate the system
into this map into this system cools
terminations again
equivalent to the convergence of this
and this but it turns out that we can
prove the determination of automatically
now if you were using the unary
[Music]
representation we could still adapt it
to represent
a func system to simulate this function
but there is no hope uh proving the
termination of that one because we can't
even
do it for way simpler maps that are
known to be convergent
so this is like the first non-trivial
test uh that the system we have
passes and here's a uh
here's the proof so these are just
matrices that are uh spit out by
[Music]
our prover that under the hood uses some
sad solver to satisfy a formula
and it solves a formula uh with
a few hundreds of thousands uh clauses
not that the size of the formula is
really indicative of its difficulty
but that's the order of the uh magnitude
of the formulas that's
uh result from this approach and
here i have some empty entries uh
although i haven't mentioned it
the matrix interpolation is actually a
simpler
version of what we are doing in reality
so there's a variant of it
where you extend the integers with minus
infinity
and change into
what is called the arctic semiring of
integers
and then that gives you another way to
prove interpretation
which is in some cases more powerful
than the matrix interpretations
so this is such a proof so the empty
entries are minus infinities
and one can check again with an
appropriate order that all of the rules
are decreasing under this interpretation
so this witness is the termination of
forecast map
and since it's uh
for the forecast system and since it's
equivalent to the
convergence of this map this proves uh
the same result that farcas had only
fully automatically so another
uh partial problem that we look at is
leaving out a rule from the original
system so this is the original
uh system that stimulates collets so
leaving out a rule from the system
can only make the problem easier at
least it cannot make the problem harder
so this gives us like an idea of where
we are in terms of
you know uh the capabilities of the
systems in handling
a system like this because if we are
unable to
solve even the uh you know slightly
easier problems
then there is no hope of solving the
original one
via such an approach but this uh
check this test we can actually uh
pass all 11 sub problems turn out to be
solvable automatically
um some are almost trivial
for instance if you remove this rule
then you're just encoding
the map that divides the number by two
and
you know termination of that with this
encoding is uh
trivial to see even for automated
methods
so there is another sense in which
this serves as a partial solution which
i haven't
completely uh described but i'll still
mention again just to give you an idea
so in reality
termination proofs are not done in a
single step you remove rules
from the system in a sequence of steps
in such a way that the smaller system's
termination implies
the termination of the whole system so
this is a technique called relative
termination
so having solved all 11 sub-problems
means that
the ability to remove any single rule
from this system via relative
termination
settles the collapse conjecture so in
some way
solves the rest of the problem the easy
part of the problem and the hard part
becomes just
finding an interpretation to remove a
single rule
and relative termination works by
ordering some of the rules non-strictly
some of the rules strictly the strict
rules
you can delete and then
the proof obligation becomes to show the
termination of the remaining rules
so this is yet another partial problem
that we looked at
so you can consider the collapse
trajectories
module or some number so this comes up
uh
mostly in the uh probabilistic study of
the collapse trajectories
but the specific problem that we are
looking at is
[Music]
is it the case that all residue classes
mod 8 are reached eventually in some
trajectory
so this graph shows how the transitions
occur
and the way to read it is if we have
some number that is
mod 3 so that is 3 mod 8
then applying the collapse rule brings
it to a number that is
2.8 if you have a number that is 2.8
then applying the collateral may either
bring it to a number that is one or
eight or five one eight
um so for this these transitions you're
able to prove automatically that
if there is a non-convergent trajectory
then it cannot avoid uh
reaching two three four and six on this
graph
uh but the and the remaining cases are
whether
uh one five and seven has to be
encountered in all trajectories
but we were unable to solve these
and these servers still weakened
variants of the
cause conjecture to tackle using these
approaches
so next i'll show you uh some more
problems that you can
uh attack using this formalism uh
that are seemingly different than the
collats conjecture but it turns out that
you can reformulate them in such a way
that
they are equivalent to the termination
of
some smallish rewriting system
so here's one problem so kurt muller
asked the following is there some
real number positive real number psi
such that
the fractional parts of psi
multiplied by 3 over 2 raised to the
power k
is strictly less than 1 over 2 for all k
it turns out that this relates to some
problems in analytic number theory
and this question has been uh open for a
long while
and i won't really describe it but i
just want to show you
that you can answer this question
negatively
by showing that this system is
terminating
and we have more details about how this
exactly goes in the paper
there's another problem that you can uh
handle in a similar manner so this can
be
seen as like a toy version of collats so
iridesce asked
uh when does the ternary expansion of
two to the n
omit the digit two so
this happens for uh n
up to eight uh so i have this conjecture
that
it doesn't happen for n greater than
nine
but again this kind of simple looking
problem is also open and you can adapt
the system that we have
uh to
[Music]
compute the ternary expansions
of the numbers by in by inverting the
rules so the
what we had can be seen as computing the
binary expansions
of mixed-based numbers by pushing binary
symbols to the right
so instead you make it so that it pushes
ternary symbols to the right
and then you delete the ternary symbols
that are zero on
one but you don't delete you keep two
and then if you are able to reach this
representation uh it means that
you've deleted all the uh zeros
and the ones and it also means that
there was no
two in the string so then you can keep
rewriting indefinitely
so in this way uh termination of this
system
for certain starting strings that are
encoding
uh the powers of two becomes a you know
gives a way to answer this question but
neither of these are again solvable or
at least we weren't able to solve it
using the methods that we have
and to conclude
some open problems so we've focused
mostly in our experiments on matrix
interpretations because they've been the
technique that's been the
most powerful in resolving
termination problems that have withstood
other techniques
but it is still worth studying the
efficacy of techniques other than matrix
interpretations
or rather you know developing some new
techniques
uh that subsume uh or are strictly more
powerful than matrix interpretations
it is also of interest to prove the
non-existence of matrix interpretations
for any dimension for the system that we
have
[Music]
which might be possible it is possible
for some concrete rewriting systems
so another thing that we can do is to
move from string to term rewriting so
terminating is more expressive and you
can
represent many kinds of computation
more compactly using term instead of
string reading
and the techniques that i've mentioned
all translate to term rewriting as well
so one question is does there exist an
even better encoding
of the collapse conjecture in terms of
term erratic
that you can approach via the same
methods
and another thing that we are unable to
do but would very much
like to do so is to inject specific
knowledge about the problem so
there are a lot of results that are
known about call-outs that could
simplify the problem but
we are unable to encode any of them or
inject any of them into the rewriting
system
or our termination proofs because it's
kind of an inflexible uh
formalism for searching for proofs so
this is
yet another thing that is of interest
and um that's it so thank you for
listening
if you have any questions i can
take them thank you emory for a great
talk
uh questions please
all right i'll start with some questions
you know about the recent proof by terry
tau
that showed that in finite there are
infinitely many
sequences of numbers where
there are no counter examples to the
collapse conjecture are you aware of
this
work um that as far as i know that only
shows that you can bound
the lengths of the trajectories
uh or the the you can show that each
number
reaches a number another number or not
each number but almost all numbers
uh under the natural density or the
integers
uh reaches a number uh
that is um
uh not strictly less than
uh the original starting number which
would allow you to
conclude the you know through the
collets conjecture
but uh like a logarithmically bounded
number so sorry i i
can restate it exactly but it doesn't
really translate because it's
it's a statement over not all initial
[Music]
numbers for which you know all of this
all of the systems and the formalisms
that we are considering
are working over uh
the worst case not the average case
and that's an average case of a kind of
results that approved
okay you would need to be able to show
that for every starting string
you reach a the collets trajectory
reaches a strictly smaller
strictly smaller number
i had one more question so instead of
trying string rewriting systems
what do you have any thoughts about you
know encoding
this as a termination of a turing
machine or
some other kind of machine um
recall that there is a paper by scott
anderson and adam utilia where they
showed
similar uh connections between
say the riemann hypothesis and um
they show the existence of a machine if
only you could show the
uh termination of that machine that
would correspond to
if i recall correctly a counter example
or something like that i i don't
exactly recall the connection but it has
some similar flavor to what
you are doing as well right so i was
wondering
what about that approach have you
thought about it yeah for collats
it's unclear whether you can do it so
because termination
is a uh pi 2 kind of statement so it's a
for all exists
kind of statement right so
in order to be able to encode it as the
termination of a turing machine
or the halting of a turing machine we
would need to be able to place
uh so we would need to be able to find a
sentence
uh a sigma one or pi one sentence
that is equivalent to the statement of
the collax conjecture and there are many
uh problems in mathematics where it's
unclear
whether that is possible so collapse is
one of them
so the best upper bound that we have is
pi 2.
uh albert sirius has a question
sorry yes i'm going to read the question
out for you
what kind of solvers do you use to find
the solutions is a propositional
set or smt cdcl local search etc
so we use propositionals we use a cdcl
set solver
ideally you would be doing this using an
smt solver because the constraints that
we have are
expressible in quantifier nia
quantified free nia so non-linear
integer arithmetic
but many people in termination community
also
found out that handcrafting their own
encodings
was uh almost always more effective than
just using smt solvers
in fact so for this work we have
implemented our
own uh solver that does a translation to
set
and even for the problems for which we
know there is an interpretation so for
instance
this interpretation it is uh
easily found by other termination tools
that
translate into set but it's not uh
found even for the correct choice of
parameters like we know the dimension
uh at which the dimension at which the
interpretation exists
so even if we make all the correct
choices for instance a
solver that uses a smt uh actually fails
to find it
in time much longer than uh it takes to
find one with sets
so local search one might try and we did
although it's not really particularly
effective uh and they're
like in the paper there are some more
discussions regarding the sad solving
aspect of this
uh so we there are some observations
that we had
uh although i didn't have time to get
into them uh now
but in the end uh encoding into sats
uh by unity blasting uh and solving via
cdcl appears to work best
at least among the things that we tried
i'm assuming the code etc is available
on github
or somewhere it will be along with so
once the conference uh
version is available and the full
version is put on archive
uh they will have i mean the code is not
the interesting part of this
general because most of these results
you can
achieve them with a few other
termination tools as well
yeah any additional questions
uh i was just wondering how big the
numbers are in your matrices
you're considering um that's a good
question
so one thing that i haven't mentioned
and nobody asked was
that while doing the search you actually
need to fix
a bounded domain where these
coefficients are coming from
in order to get a finite formula
so as you can see for instance here
in the interpretations the largest
occurring value is four
but uh in the cell encoding you need to
mention uh
the result the the variables that will
occur in the interpretations of the
rules as well
so for this specific example 8 is the
largest number that occurs
and we bit blast using a unary encoding
and since it's more propagation friendly
compared to using a logarithmic encoding
and
for instance i don't have it
in the paper in the slides but for one
of these systems
there is an interpretation that uses
values up to
30 that are currently interpretation
although
i'm and we are only able to find it
because it's so low dimensional it's it
uses just
two dimensional matrices where the
largest occurring value anywhere in the
interpretations is 30
so that results in a you know feasible
formula to
solve okay thank you
final question do you have any hope of
solving the collapse conjecture with
this method
all right probably not but it's very
addicting to try
yeah um well the the the the thing about
uh these is you can like the one
particular thing about
the choice of matrix interpretations is
you can scale them
and they are known to have a proper
hierarchy of problems
uh that are solvable via you know given
dimension
so one can hope that increasing the num
increasing the dimension can you know
after a long search
uh lead to an interpretation but as i
said may also be the case that no
interpretation exists
there are like concrete examples of
rewriting systems
for which there is probably no no matrix
interpretation
because the existence of a matrix
interpretation actually
places some constraints on the longest
derivations
in the system that in the rewriting
system that you can have
and so systems that have two long
derivations
do not admit matrix interpretation
proofs although they are provable by
other methods
any additional questions if not
let's thank emery for a fantastic talk
thank you all right so with that we
close this session
and i believe that at 2 p.m is there a
gather town
uh i don't know maybe is that a gather
town at 2pm
or believe you're free to join get join
gather town
at 11 a.m uh psd ppt right
all right thank you everybody bye bye
thank you bye-bye thanks